[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
happy tuesday my friendly friends in
breaking news to report did you know
what's destroying america
adjectives
yes it's true words like cruel rough
sharp gentle sleek slippery sounds like
last night in hammer's hot tub
anyway adjectives are bad which is also
an adjective so how bad is bad sorry
well dana milbank some old crank from
the washington post commissioned a
report that counted adjectives in the
coverage of our last two presidents and
he found that joe is the target of way
more negative words than the previous
president who you remember the evil
orange monster from planet hitler
so what's the proof milbank actually had
a firm count adjectives and articles
comparing what biden received in the
first 11 months of 2021 to trump in the
first 11 months of 2020. they called
this sentiment analysis
the authorities did the same thing to my
diary after i burned down that men's big
and tall store
the conclusion the media is meaner to
joe than trump now that makes about as
much sense as a chicken in a thong
it's like me at a wet market selling bat
nachos no one should buy it
still according to the firm's vp the
media are serving as accessories to the
murder of democracy
and those murder weapons
are adjectives
so in short a biased writer at a biased
paper commissioned a biased firm to
study media bias and surprise he thinks
the media is biased against joe biden
how convenient
here's milbank regurgitating the data on
cnn
the last four months however
uh biden has been uh
at where donald trump was or
lower than where donald trump is in
terms of media sentiment i mean it's not
bias it's the actual words we're using
so
we are as negative as a collective media
on joe biden if not more so
than we were to donald trump at a time
when he was trying to overthrow
democracy and i think that's a
tremendous indictment of our whole
industry you know it's not foolproof but
it gives a pretty good number and we
never had such a number before yes they
never had such a number before because
this is the first time you did it and
you were the one who commissioned it
what a circle of jerks
[Laughter]
so as usual the media's lies are like
stelter's man boobs they just keep
getting bigger and bigger
and this analysis has more holes in it
than the ceiling of the spare room that
i rent out to college students
i'm dressing this thing up it's obvious
to anyone alive the past five years that
the media's treatment of trump was way
worse with or without adjectives they
are obsessed with trump and they still
can't let him go no one's asking alec
baldwin to do a biden impersonation
although no one's asking alec anything
unless they're behind bulletproof glass
looks great though for example only 19
of biden's first 60 days have been
negative impressive when you consider he
was unconscious for 50 of them
now that ranked best among presidents of
the last three decades trump's first 60
days received a 62 negative rating the
fact is the press didn't just report on
trump they led the resistance covering
every protest and every march trump was
treated worse than charlie sheen at a
blood bank
that's pretty good but you should you
should
you should already know this and if you
don't you're probably some drunk guy in
underwear dancing on a bar counter
nice try now milbank claims the media
was very kind to biden until august then
something happened what could it be
afghans scrambling to get out clinging
to the side of a us military plane where
is the president you know why why isn't
he communicating
wholesomely to the american people
they knew exactly what it took in order
to accomplish this mission and for some
inexplicable reason there was nothing
but complacency and
inaction and in the end ineptitude it is
just a picture
of
desperation
of
failure as well failure to protect our
allies
failure to plan for this eventuality
so that's what happened of course
milbank sees the downturn as evil bias
when in reality the media could no
longer cover for biden's wrinkled butt
since the public could see his
incompetence with their own eyes there
was no spin between the afghan disaster
and the viewer the implosion was right
there for all to see but what milbank
twists as media bias is a somber
realization that the horse they backed
broke its ankle going into the first
turn and is too old to put out to stud
it used to be they could cover for joe
literally they let him live in a
basement like a millennial with a
liberal arts degree while he was running
for president we only heard from him
when dr jill went down to do laundry
he was the first to campaign standing
next to a washer dryer and a litter box
and then when that story about hunter's
laptop came out they buried it faster
than the guy in the trunk of henry
hill's car
a good fella's reference and speaking of
hunter because no one really is this
week the white house flagged the art
industry as a corrupt enterprise due to
lack of transparency and unpredictable
pricing meaning that you could charge
someone hundreds of thousands of dollars
for crappy art and get away with it
so what does that sound like to you
yeah the white house is blasting art
industry corruption as they allow hunter
to sell his artwork to anonymous buyers
for a half million why isn't that a
story does it have too many adjectives
sleazy gross infantile coke-fueled
all of the above but it's just another
cover-up just like all the others and
remember the institutions that swayed
the election actually bragged about it
in time magazine as tech the media and
other groups came together to drag old
joe across the finish line that meant
not reporting on the riots and the
rising crime denouncing any mention of
the hunter laptop or the big guy's links
to china i wonder what the president has
to say
look look everybody knows the press is
tough on me all right
they certainly don't cozy up to me the
way they did my predecessor i'll tell
you that
but we got a good team we fight back
ron clayne
bring the pain
jen sackey circle back e
i know how to fight all right
you come at me i'll take you down
uh i i fought in the six day war with
gold in my ear
that's that's real
and uh i give her credit but without me
that would have lasted seven eight days
minimum that's true
i'm serious
i'm not joking about that
so
the media's realized that they married a
corpse and it's starting to rot but it's
not just joe's rotting it's the media no
one is buying their bs anymore not even
the left so like newlyweds returning
from barbados milbank realizes the fun
part is done and reality sets in so he
creates new bs to paper over the old bs
but hey maybe we need more soul
searching
i think we really need to do some soul
searching and think about what it is
we're delivering uh to people uh and i
think the media consumer may uh you know
should should look at what we're saying
uh with a grain of salt we do
sorry dana to do any soul-searching
first you need a soul
and the will to search it the media the
media's got neither
[Applause]
welcome tonight's guest
he's been on more film sets than cocaine
and crap services actor author of the
book the respondent and founder of the
charity children and parents united greg
ellis
her pronouns are y'all and bless your
heart fox business network anchor jagged
mcdowell
she knits her old hair extensions into
sweaters for the four bucks his
contributor cat tim
and nothing gets in his way except
ceilings door frames and shower curtain
rods my massive sidekick in the nwa
world television champion again
cyrus
i don't know where to start tyrus
congrats did you win oh i won yeah i won
uh
and still and still undisputed reigning
defending well and you won yeah we well
we're only all one together that one
we're all winning we're all winning
we're just a bunch of winners we are a
bunch of winners so let's talk about the
loot let's talk about the losers all
right what do you think of this well i
think it's funny because
the one was intended to get a result
attack him attack him throw stuff on the
wall he's got to do something but
president trump was just
too smooth and too slick i mean
everything any allegation accusation
that would get a book deal or some half
a criminal a chance to run for president
iowa
they would do it
and they would go at him go at him but
while that was going on there was these
good deeds happening
our border was secure our economy was up
we had jobs we had opportunities
now
they're doing the truman show
with
president biden yeah
and
we've already seen the movie right
you can't trick us that is a great point
from the young
championship uh wrestler
kagan surprising it's almost an oxymoron
but it just works
yeah i said that word big right i love
i love how uh this guy milbank keeps
saying that like it's not fair because
uh you know trump was trying to
overthrow democracy and all biden did
was like screw up the economy or
something it was like it's that's a
bizarre way of creating a story i think
that kind of the media abandoned
together to ensure that one party always
wins versus another is kind of
anti-democracy right or you know what's
anti-democracy communism and and joe
biden gets like tummy squiggles every
time he's like even on a zoom call with
she or putin yes so i think that's kind
of more of a danger to democracy but
these media grifters are the ones who
sold this squinty
cracked garden gnome to the american
people
and so they're they got a butt rash
anytime anybody criticizes him right
because admitting his failures is
admitting their own and you brought up
hunter by i can't for the life of me
figure out there were like a bunch of
new york times reporters who for a year
all they did was go through trump's
financial documents and his tax returns
they don't want to be on the hunter
biden beat learning to work learning to
work a poll yes and blow some
paint
and just like get to the bottom of what
does it take to get kicked out of the
chateau mermod yeah
you're absolutely right
you're right you know what and i'm also
glad
i'm glad the the the word you used after
blow was paint
because i think we all felt that it
might have been done
no okay
but if i were a journalist yeah i know i
would love to follow hunter biden around
think of that you could take you're the
king of comedy we got it we're on the
mountain don't do it but you can follow
you can expense strip club
yes you can't do that in real life
they'll fix it in post yes
greg what did you make of this uh this
incredible research counting adjectives
well first of all i think i counted 369
adjectives in your monologue
um
look i i think you know this gallows
tonal policing of what's going on is
it's just indicative of this division
there's no bipartisanship anymore i mean
just before i came on air a couple hours
ago i talked with uh representative
rodney creech in ohio who's passing the
first or was dropped onto the floor the
first equal shared parenting bill in
ohio which is following kentucky and
arkansas these are the kinds of bills
that need to be furthered uh normally
these kinds of bills are co-sponsored by
about 15 people the 58 co-sponsors on
this bill and those kinds of policies
and laws um at the the at the state
level and the local level um that's what
we need to be focusing on and and
bipartisanship and i don't see too much
of that from this this president who's a
catholic he's a father and a family man
if he really cared about families he'd
be he'd really get into passing this
kind of legislation that really helps
children and parents across america he
can't you know there's only a few things
he can pass
oops
[Applause]
you hit the driver but you know what i'm
not gonna i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
complete the sentence you can't yeah i'm
not gonna complete the sentence see i've
grown up i've listened
to the advice
i'm no longer doing fart poop
oh we're back there
[Applause]
so cat what do you make of this uh this
you know it was a slow news day
excellent question
[Laughter]
look i don't it's not that i don't trust
data
i don't trust someone being like oh
we'll cause data yeah a lot of times
it's
i looked at the actual stories
that uh one of the ones that was you
know they were judging to attribute what
the media's tone is about joe biden the
headline was
uh haiti president assassinated at home
wife wounded so i don't doubt that there
were many negative adjectives used to
describe that sequence of events no but
i don't know what it has to do with joe
biden right oh that they actually use
that one yeah there's nothing so it's
you know a lot of people who actually
know what they're talking about with you
know data and analysis and technology uh
they're saying this was bad so i trust
them more than me this doesn't make
sense to anyone who's a human brain but
also if you look at it you can just say
data just like how the science people do
it right they use the science words and
you're like oh they must be smarter than
i am and i just don't understand the
data people do the same thing yes
exactly so he created the he had the
idea fulfilled the idea with the data
that he created himself by having
somebody count adjectives and the guy
who counted him said this is there's so
many more ways to be mean to people than
an adjective yeah that is true you know
like just the things that they did not
cover about biden that they would have
covered about trump cat words of
violence though
words
yes exactly hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else